>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Today is a special vision to
imagine a biography as literary,
you know, the story arc
is not yours to chart.
A life was lived and an author
as skilled as Stacy Schiff has
to respect the facts of that life.
But within those confines, she
was among a very few writers
who can infuse true long ago stories
with the benefits of storytelling.
Gorgeous sentences are
essential, but also,
an ability to infuse emotion and
enliven events that she did not see,
but surely, someone else did.
Prize awarding panels
anticipate each of her next books
like a time travel experience
that readers could not have
known were available to them.
Through her extraordinary efforts,
readers get an intimate portrait,
for instance, of the half century
Nabokov marriage, in which husband
and wife were equally committed,
not just to a literally livelihood,
but to a transportation out
of quotidian household woes
and toward a lofty, idealistic
dual commitment to art.
Similarly, she has sent
readers aloft into the mysteries
of "The Aviator" and "Little Prince"
author, Antoine de Saint-Exupery,
and then later, endeavoring to
revisit the Boulevard des years
of a founding father in Paris.
I keep thinking of her recent book
as Benjie Franklin, The Sexy Years.
[ Laughter ]
>> That's preparation, of course,
for her next, which is Cleopatra.
On behalf of the festival organizers
and the many indefatigable
volunteers today, and of course,
my hardworking colleagues
at the Washington Post,
I'm honored to welcome and
to hear from Stacy Schiff.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thanks for turning out.
I suspect you're all melting out
there 'cause I'm melting up here.
If you inferred from these
remarks that I have no life
of my own, you are correct.
But I have been through this
biography business a few times,
and I have the following
observation to offer.
No matter how wisely, how
careful you choose your subject,
you wind up with one
of two problems.
You either have the needle in
the haystack problem as I did
when I started out on
the life of Mrs. Nabokov,
the wife of the writer, a woman who
was pathologically private, stoic,
selfless, formal, all qualities
that make for a lousy book, or--
and nothing could be
worse, I decided after this.
And so, I went on to write a book
about Benjamin Franklin's
exhaustively documented years
in France, thereby incurring the
haystack in the haystack problem,
in which I assure you,
nothing could be worse.
For those eight years that
Franklin spends in France,
that they're the eight years of the
American Revolution and the peace
that follows, the documentation here
in America is two and a half times
as great as it is for the
rest of his life combined.
And that's not counting
the French materials.
In Paris, Franklin was
surrounded by a net of French spies
who were surrounded by
a net of British spies,
and as far as I can tell, each of
these men was paid by the word.
Nothing, nothing-- I promise you--
was too trivial for them to
report on, including the state
of Franklin's laundry, which
was always immaculately white,
and his dinner menu.
There was a precocious
amount of apple pie consumed
by his household, by the way.
Everyone who owned a pen wrote
a memoir in the 18th century,
and those who didn't
appear to own a newspaper.
They were both official
French newspapers
and unofficial French newspapers,
and their reports reliably
contradicted each other.
I might add that John Adams
was also in Paris at the time.
He appears to have
owned several pens.
He missed his wife dreadfully,
he had very little to do,
and he wrote a great deal
about Benjamin Franklin.
But that's another story.
I should also say, actually,
in deference to Richard Holmes,
I thought of Richard Daley--
because I spent a year and a half
in Paris doing this research-- most
of Franklin's materials did not get
through to the American Congress.
So the best place to
read them is the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs in Paris.
And Richard has a wonderful line on
one f his essays about the problem
with doing any kind
of research in Paris,
is that if your editor calls you
and they find that you're not home,
they assume that you're
out having a good time.
I just wanna go in
the record of saying
that I wasn't having a good time.
I was in the archives
everyday, which was great
if you don't mind working under low
light and turning over your passport
and arriving at the appointed
time and reserving your documents
in advance and filling out a
pass to go to the ladies room
and not complaining when the
archivist go out on strike.
[ Laughter ]
>> So what then did
Benjamin Franklin
and Cleopatra have in common?
Or put another way, why would a
relatively experienced predominantly
sane biographer, who is neither
Greek nor Latin, and who's happiest
in a dusty archive, attempt a
biography of a 1st century queen.
Let me say at the outset that
I didn't think entirely--
I wasn't entirely sure
it was possible.
I'd had Cleopatra in my mind
as a subject for a long time,
but I just didn't see a way to write
a traditional chronicle of her life.
She fascinated me for
every possible reason.
I kept thinking of her as
that sort of rare combination
of Delilah meets Catherine the
Great meets Jackie O, you know.
It was sort of history and
legend all bound together.
And from the biographer's
point of view,
this was really the Mount Everest.
The idea struck me less though
as biography than paleontology.
We may live in the post-factual
age as someone recently said,
but she lived in a pre-factual one.
I was probably most fascinated
because I was startled
by my own ignorance.
Here was a woman whom we think of
as Egyptian, but who was in fact,
Greek, whom we remember
as beautiful,
but whom every ancient chroniclers
swore was more intelligent
and more charming than
she was beautiful.
Here was a woman whom we had
somehow conflated with Nefertiti
who lived 1300 years
before Cleopatra,
and to whom Cleopatra
was not even related.
And here was a woman who
successfully ruled a rich
and fractious country
for over two decades.
She's the only woman in
antiquity who ruled by herself,
whom we have reduced to
the slinky seductress.
She was however, and not so
incidentally, the richest person,
man or woman, in the
Mediterranean world,
she lived in the most
cultured city of her day.
Alexandria at the time is really
the center of culture of all.
Rome is still a backwater.
And hers was the most
enlightened of atmospheres.
She knew things that would be
forgotten until the renaissance,
the value of pie, the
behavior of linear perspective,
the existence of the equator.
And gender mattered less than
competence in her palace,
as it did generally
in Egypt at the time.
In Cleopatra's Egypt, women
operated mills, and they owned land,
they leased vineyards, they divorced
husbands, they inherited equally.
In short, they enjoyed rights
that they would not again enjoy
for something like 2000 years.
And yet, after all of that,
Cleopatra melt into a puddle
of myths and misconceptions.
She has become to us a
cigarette, a mascara, a videogame,
a slot machine, a strip club, or
a synonym for Elizabeth Taylor.
And at this time of year, you will
see her name all over the internet
because hers is the most
popular of Halloween costumes.
Someone asked me recently
when I realized
that this book could
actually be written,
and I answered a little
glibly but not inaccurately,
that I realized it could be
written when I finished writing it,
but there was another moment.
There was one other moment in truth.
It was when I finally
noticed that we had an act--
we had actual 2000 year
old quotes from Cleopatra,
and that we could hear just the
tiniest murmur of her voice.
For the most part,
that's thanks to Plutarch.
On the one hand, it pays to remember
that Plutarch was writing a good
century after Cleopatra's death.
He is as far removed from her
as we are from Ulysses grant.
On the other, as a modern
biographer recently reminded me,
there were no tape recorders
in the 19th century either.
It goes without saying that quoted
material is generally approximate.
And as I learned from Ben Franklin,
even the most comprehensive material
can refuse to give up answers.
Probably, I couldn't see
my way to writing Cleopatra
until those years buried
in Franklin's archive.
Five years in those miles and miles
of paper, and I still can't tell you
who the mother of his son was.
I doubt anyone ever will.
And I knew there were questions
that could never be answered,
but I also knew that that had
nothing to do with the millennia
that separate us from Cleopatra.
What went on between Virginia
Woolf and her brother,
how did Shelley die, what
was the problem really
with Emily Dickinson,
where is Jimmy Hoffa.
None of these questions
have answers either.
In some cases, they have answers--
they don't have answers because we
have an overload of information.
Too many accounts can
spoil the truth.
How then was it possible
to write about her?
I should probably mention
at this juncture
that I'm here on false pretenses.
It is true that I have written
a biography of Cleopatra,
but it is not true that you can
buy it today, because it isn't
on sale for another two weeks.
But then you can buy it.
You could buy several
copies, in fact.
And the one-- and it's beautiful,
so you might wanna buy one
for your living room table
and the other to read.
And the one you wanna buy is the
one with my name, Stacy Schiff,
on it, not the other one.
Anyway, its publication
date is November 1st.
But let me go back to that line of
dialogue and Plutarch for a minute.
>> It comes in the course of a
marvelous account of Cleopatra
and Mark Antony out fishing on a
carefree Alexandrian afternoon.
Plutarch meant to use the incident
to illustrate what he calls
Antony's boyish pranks,
but it offers something
else as well.
The most accomplished
military commander of his day,
Antony is unable to
lure a single fish
from the fertile waters of Egypt.
Humiliated, it's always worse
when you have your girlfriend
at your side and even worse
when she's the queen of Egypt,
he arranges for one of his servants
to attach several pre-caught
fish to his line.
And these, he begins to reel in one
after the other with great gusto.
The scam is not lost in Cleopatra.
She is competitive by nature, and
she has very impish sense of humor.
And so, she arranges for
all of their friends to come
and watch her highly skilled
roman friend the next day.
When she also arranges is
for one of her servants
to attach an imported salted
herring to Mark Antony's hook,
and this he pulls from the waters
of Egypt to peals of laughter.
On the spot, she advises him to
forget about fishing and attend
to his real responsibilities.
He is meant to be hunting,
not for fish, but for cities,
kingdoms, and continents.
She's sly and she's saucy, but
there is also something a little bit
familiar on her tone.
It's one known to every woman whose
husband owns a set of golf clubs.
Of course, it also made me
wonder about Plutarch's wife.
So yes, there were some
terrific constraints.
I was used to knowing what
my subject had had for dinner
and what he or she fretted
about before he fell asleep.
And in this case, the record
was as skewed as it was spotty.
All bets were off.
The Nile is not where it used to
be, ancient Alexandria is lost,
some of it is in the harbor of
Alexandria, and I don't scuba dive.
The Egyptian coastline has changed,
so have the language, the culture,
the religion on the calendar.
Don't even ask me about the prices.
And you have to get used
to counting backward too.
I mean, Cleopatra was born
in '69 and she dies in 30 BC.
This drove the copy editor crazy.
Essentially, you check all
your preconceptions at the door
when you enter the world of
Ptolemies, Cleopatra's dynasty.
It's difficult to write
about maternity in a family
where children routinely
poisoned their parents
and parents dismember
their children.
This was admittedly new to me.
At the same time, great literature
is about ambiguity, and it struck me
that biography could
occasionally afford to be as well.
You can't demand order, even
answers, at the classical world.
And arguably, you rarely can at all
when it comes to the human heart.
But you can do a lot with it,
especially given the last 50 years
of fine scholarship on
the Hellenistic World.
Virginia Woolf once remarked
of an imperfect novel
that the string didn't
quite unite the pearls,
but that the pearls were there.
That was very much on
my mind as I worked,
as was Julian Barnes' great
alternate definition of a net,
a series of holes tied
together by string.
There were huge unknowns, but
there were no knowns among them,
several subjects that no one
had really approached before.
For starters, there
was Cleopatra's wealth.
There was her relationship
with Herod
and how the two rulers dealt very
differently with the rise of Rome.
There was her education about
which we can be really specific
and which reveals a great deal
about how she thought and spoke,
and of course, I have
one terrific advantage.
Human nature is remarkably constant.
It has changed not one iota
since the 1st Century BC.
You can read Cicero and
how not to spoil a child,
you can read countless text and
how women are shrill and unbending
in their demands, but
loose in their morals.
They should stay home and
take care of the children.
A friend of one's friend
was already one's enemy.
Essentially, every
problem that Cleopatra had
with Rome is the problem that
a woman in power faces today
with very little variation and
arguably, better birth control.
The successful woman is
sexualized, shrill, and unnatural.
And when a woman sleeps with two of
the most successful and powerful men
of her day, she is a seductress,
even if both of those men happened
to be celebrated for their
voracious sexual appetite.
It helps to remember, by the way,
that the commentators are human too,
and we, all of us, write in
the time in which we live.
Let me give you just one example.
At the end of one of the best 20th
Century biography of Cleopatra,
we see Cleopatra preparing to
meet Octavian who's defeated her.
She has been on a hunger strike.
It's the two of their
first interview,
and its days before
she will kill herself.
Here is how the biographer
introduces this fraught
and critical moment.
I quote, "She was essentially
a woman.
And now, in her condition
of physical weakness,
she acted precisely as any
other overwrought member
of her sex might have behaved
under similar circumstances."
How we constitute and
reconstitute history was
on my mind all the way
through as I worked.
This of course, is a central
problem always in writing history.
Those closest to events
have the best information
and the most at stake.
The most informed source is
also the most involved source,
the later chroniclers know
less, but they can say more.
With each book, I've been well
into the work before I realized
that there was something
utterly rudimentary
that I had forgotten to research.
In this case, it was that I needed
to understand precisely who the men
who left as Cleopatra's story were.
I had gone to the desert
where Cleopatra was exiled.
I had soaked up the Alexandrian
color, all of it before I realize
that I needed to know my sources,
as well as I knew my subject.
Of those who actually knew
Cleopatra and who wrote
about her, there are three.
Julius Caesar who was married to
someone else during their affair
and focused on Rome and
understandably reluctant
to mention Cleopatra,
Nicolaus of Damascus,
the source for her dealings with
Herod who had been the tutor
to her children and who
changed sides after her death,
and Cicero who rarely had
a kind word for anyone
and who could really not stomach
a smart, rich, educated woman
with a quick wit and a
better library than he had.
I tried to always keep in
mind who was a sensationalist
and who was scold, who
had set eyes on Egypt,
and who despised the place.
From those endless French
newspapers of the 1770's,
I knew the difference too,
between propaganda and hearsay.
In Cleopatra's case, we
owe a huge debt to both.
Biased and inaccurate
though they may have been,
the Romans who left us her
story did us a tremendous favor.
Normally, women are
difficult to write about,
they keep lousy records,
and their lives tend
to slip through the cracks.
Cleopatra owes her
immortality to her enemies.
Had they hated her less, they would
not have preserved her for us.
She's one of the few women
in history whose detractors have
enlarged, rather than erased,
her role, just one of the
few losers whom we remember.
Had she been a man, she would
have been forgotten today,
like most of the other eastern
sovereigns whom Rome eliminated.
And for the record, had
Rome not intervened,
had Cleopatra been
dealt a stronger hand,
she would have faced a different
but equally vicious enemy.
In the normal course of events, she
would have been deposed, poisoned,
or hacked to pieces, or exiled
by one of her own four children,
in which case, we would never
have heard of her at all.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Any questions?
>> Yeah. Thank you.
Could you say something about
how well Cleopatra understood the
strategies that the different
Roman factions were practicing
against her, and therefore kind
of assess her political
acuity and deftness?
Thank you.
>> That's a great question.
Essentially, what Cleopatra is left
with is a Rome completely pulled
apart by civil wars, and especially
after Caesar's death,
the great conundrum
for her is whom to side with.
I mean, she has banked entirely on
Caesar, she's in Rome at the time
of his murder, she may in fact be
contributing factor to his murder,
and all chaos, as many of you
know, suddenly breaks loose.
So which of the possible
successors should she side with?
And it's very clear that
for the first year or so,
she tries to sit things out.
Everyone comes calling, it's almost
like a fairytale moment where,
you know, each picture in turn
comes to see if she will back them,
and she definitely temporizes.
There's a real hesitation
there to figure
out whom she should
ally herself with.
And of course, in the end,
she chooses Mark Antony,
Caesar's protege.
It's interesting when
you think about it
because had she allied herself
with Octavian who becomes Augustus,
who would have seen the
unlikeliest of choices,
all would have worked
out very differently.
But at that time, he seemed like
he was entirely the dark horse
and Antony made a great
deal of sense.
And what's fascinating there is just
the way she adapts herself to each
of the factions in turn and does try
to do her best to supply everyone
with what he asks so
as to hedge her bets.
There's a real sense of
political strategy with her.
Yes?
>> I wondered what languages
besides Latin you had to work off
of for your original sources,
and did you have any issues
with the translations that were
made of these original sources.
>> The only two languages that-- as
a smart person would have learned
for this book where Latin and
Greek, neither of which I have.
What I did do, and which
helped tremendously,
was to compare translations, because
needless to say, over the years,
there have been rather
a few translations
of Suetonius or Plutarch or Dio.
>> And in some-- in
comparing those translations,
a lot of nuance falls out.
So there was a great deal
for me of going back and back
over various passages with someone
who is, in fact, an expert in Greek,
and trying to see what
meanings I could leach
from sort of between the lines.
It's a nightmare for me not
to be able to speak a language
in which these sources exist.
On the other hand, these
sources are so much later.
These are-- these men
are writing 100 and 150
and 200 years after Cleopatra.
I didn't feel as if
the literal word,
there were no letters
from Cleopatra.
There was, alas, no diary.
So I didn't feel as if my being
unable to read her was going
to be an issue, as it would
have with the Nabokov's.
The Nabokov's did me a huge
favor, because in their letters,
when they wrote something
intimate to each other,
they broke from Russian and
they wrote it in French,
which I do speak and read.
So that they could be talking
about, you know, who was gonna take
out the laundry in Russian, and
then it would suddenly break
in into this wonderfully
intimate romantic paragraph
of French, blessedly.
Yes?
>> Would you-- can you hear me?
What do you think of
Cleopatra's political background?
>> I'm sorry, Cleopatra's?
>> Political background.
>> Her political background?
>> Yeah.
>> That's a good question.
She was clearly schooled to rule
and in those days what was great
or what was interesting anyway is
that pretty much anyone of the--
any one of the children was
educated in the same way.
And it's fairly clear to us today.
And this was something that
fascinated me which it seemed
to me now when I touched before.
It's pretty clear what
she would have read
and what she would have studied.
And in fact her education,
her sense of rhetoric,
her training in rhetoric would
have been nearly identical
to that of Caesar.
And the text that were known
to her and memorized by her,
much of it Homer, Aeschylus,
Euripides were the same texts
that anyone living
anywhere in the Greek world,
anyone of an elite
education living anywhere
in the Greek world
would also have known
so that you very much
spoke a common language.
And it was from those texts that you
really drew your political lessons.
Did she know her Egyptian history?
I can't imagine she didn't.
Have we any proof of that?
No. Yes?
>> Would you say that
there is any woman today
that symbolizes Cleopatra's
situation?
>> I have a hard time
thinking of anyone
who would dismember her children.
>> They may have political--
>> Although actually no, I
don't I can't think of someone.
[Laughter] No.
I think that, I think the gustiness
of Cleopatra I mean I think
there's a huge amount of strategy.
This was a woman who was a champion
strategist and who could be ruthless
and who could truly plot
out a military campaign.
Is there an exact parallel
to that of someone today?
No. But I think there are numerous
women we could all name who've shown
those qualities.
What's unusual about
Cleopatra is that she comes
from a line of female rulers.
She has plenty of female
role models.
So there have been, there were
other women in Egyptian history
who had done what she did,
whereas for us this is now
something of a novelty.
So she's coming at it interestingly
in a less traditional
way than we are.
>> I think I've broken it.
I'm just wondering why
you have chosen biography
as your particular form
of historical writing.
Do you think biography helps
us get at certain political
or historical social
questions in a different way,
or do you think it lands more
compelling research and writing?
>> You know, someone once described
biography I think very accurately
as gossip with footnote.
[Laughter] I'm really
good on the footnotes,
although I never knew I
wrote vertical footnotes
until Richard spoke just now.
Human nature interest me greatly and
I think as a reader I always prefer
to come to my history through
the character of someone else
and through the live intelligence
and personality of someone else.
It just makes it more accessible.
Somehow, it makes it more exciting,
but that's my reader's answer.
My writer's answer is that
I quick early on discovered
that I loved having
this parallel existence,
that I loved living two lives.
I've long wanted to write an essay
about how the biographer's two
lives, the life she writes about
but she understands
and the life she lives
of which she is completely clueless.
And there's the sense there always
of just being able to see the world
through two different optics
which I find hugely appealing.
And the other and obvious reason I
suppose is that when I began writing
and I have no idea how to write a
book, although I had been an editor,
biography appealed because it
has a very natural beginning,
middle and end.
And it's a very easy kind of--
it seemed to me a relatively
easy thing to structure.
There's also a very gratifying
element to biography of course
which is that no matter
what happens,
in the end you get
to kill your subject.
[ Laughter ]
[ Pause ]
>> Two quick questions.
What are you reading now
and what are some ideas
for future biographies?
>> Just a little louder.
>> What are you reading now
and what are some future ideas
for biographies, individuals?
>> What I'm reading now is almost
inevitably fiction and I don't know
if that's because I feel
nonfiction as homework but I--
or because I just-- I so-- and I'm
such a sucker for literary style
that I would almost always prefer to
pick up a novel then I were to pick
up a biography which I
can always be guaranteed
to find perfect satisfaction.
And so what I'm reading now
and of course we're all reading now
is the Franzen, and what I'm reading
after that is just 'cause it's on
the night table is A Happy Marriage.
But it's all fiction.
There is nothing--
oh, that's not true.
Run true now is George Washington
biography is on the table.
But you know what, it's
gonna sink to the bottom.
I can tell you now.
As for my next subject,
like Richard I don't have
to answer that question.
But if any of you has an idea,
please talk to me later, okay?
>> Can you say a little bit more
about the tradition of female rulers
that Cleopatra came from?
>> Cleopatra, as I said, is
the only ruler, the only woman
in antiquity to have ruled alone.
For reasons that are not
entirely clear at least to me,
there is a huge sense of equality
among the Ptolemies, her dynasty.
The women and the men are equally
gifted at making decisions.
Most of the other women who do rule
either rule temporarily or rule
in tandem with a little brother
or a husband or a brother
to whom she is married
for that matter,
which is not Cleopatra's case.
But there doesn't seem to be
a very serious distinction
between the genders
in terms of ruling.
It seems either one of us it seems
to have gone over perfectly well.
I'm sorry.
I just forgot what I
was supposed to say.
And where this comes from,
I mean, whether this is
because the goddess Isis is
such a powerful influence,
whether it's because it is--
there's just a sense that women
and men have been ruling
beautifully together for so long,
whether it's because some of
those earlier Ptolemaic queens
where incredibly effective,
cruel but effective, is unclear.
But what becomes abundantly clear is
that there was really no problem
accepting a female pharaoh
when Cleopatra came to the throne.
It also-- it makes-- she makes
it much easier by getting rid
of her brothers and her other sister
which is always a helpful thing
to do when you're a monarch.
>> You mentioned that there are no
letters or diaries from Cleopatra,
so how do we know so much
about her personality?
>> I'm still looking for the diary.
How we know about the personality,
I thought those little glimpses
like the line I talked
about from Plutarch.
And again here you're
squaring sources.
But what's interesting is how
much the sources tend to repeat
or echo each other so that the
impishness that I referred to,
for example her response to Antony
on the fishing expedition is very
much mirrored in other accounts
in which she is irreverent and sly
and by no means a docile
and unassuming presence.
So I was taking my cues
from the material we have
which is I say is 100 or 200
or 300 years after her birth.
But time moved differently
in those days.
I don't need to tell you this.
It was slower in those days.
And there is a sense that
these stories that were handed
down were being handed
down with some consistency.
>> In response to your
request for a new topic,
I think John Hay [phonetic]
would be--
>> Thank you.
>> -- a good one.
[Laughter] I don't think that there
has been a one volume good biography
on him but I also do
have a question.
As somebody who myself would one day
like to enter the historical writing
field, so now as I feel overwhelmed
by the fact that so much has
already been written and obviously
when you write something new you
don't wanna repeat what others have
already said.
You want your own perspective,
something new, something different,
something that's not
gonna bore people.
How do you go finding your own
personal perspective on subjects?
>> That's also a great question.
I long ago interviewed
Joe Ellis [phonetic]
from something I was writing
about the anxiety of influence
with the previous biographers
and I asked him
where do you read the
secondary sources?
I think I was working on
Ben Franklin at that time.
Do you read the 376 other Franklin
biographies, and he was very clear
about saying that is
essentially a Bermuda Triangle.
Do not go there.
You will never emerge.
You will spend the next five years
reading the secondary sources.
>> So what I have done in so far
as I have been saying about that is
to decide that it's my
Franklin or it's my Cleopatra.
And what's different are
not necessarily the answers
or the materials, it's
the questions we ask.
So I'm bringing to the
subject questions or problems
that the previous biographer
didn't bring
or the previous hundred
biographers didn't bring and that
that those secondary materials
are just gonna have to lie there.
It's easier when you
don't have to read them.
For this book I felt there were
some secondary sources I had to read
because there was so
little primary material.
For Ben Franklin, it was really easy
to ignore all secondary
materials except one
that concerned minor characters.
I mean, I think I read a lot of
biographies of the Lee brothers,
the people who came in
peripherally to my story.
Yes?
>> How do you know somebody hasn't
asked it if you haven't read them?
[ Laughter ]
>> That's a great question.
I don't. I could be wrong.
I'll just cross my fingers.
We're done.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.